hello everyone my name is
today we will talk the necessary
conditions in multi-server differential
privacy this is a joint work with
artboard II in Georgetown University
in this work
we prove some problems need exponential
numbers of samples to be solved in the
multi-server differential privacy
and it tells us that if we want to
soften with polynomial normal number of
samples we need interaction of servers
or computational differential privacy
we are at first introduced the
definition of differential privacy
and the centralized and decentralized
models in differential privacy and the
possibilities and the impossibilities of
these models and then we will talk about
our results and the techniques in the
proof
so what is differential privacy
uh we say that people cannot know if one
person is in the database by the result
of differential privacy algorithm
we defined the neighboring databases x
and x Prime to be two databases that
differ on one entry
and if a DP algorithm m is wrong on one
of the two Neighbors The Anniversary
cannot tell which one was the import
we use Epsilon and data to quantify the
advantage of the adversary
the distribution of MX and the MX Prime
should satisfy this in equality
we usually use Epsilon to measure the
privacy of the algorithm M and the data
to be the tiny probability of leaking
the privacy
in the centralized model there is one
server that computes the private
algorithm on data
and the the adversary rate can only view
the output of the server
but the adversary could view the raw
data if the server is compromised in
response we can keep the raw data out of
the
server's View
so we can decentralize the Privacy
preservation process in this work we
studied the model with several untrusted
servers
for example this is a q server protocol
in this protocol each user runs a
randomizer on their data
now the first user
generate y11 and the y12 and since y11
qa1
y12 to the A2
and the last user sends yn1 to B1 and
sends Y and Q to A2
so first is server A1 then sends some
messages to AQ
and A2 computes the output
this is a non-interactive case the A2
cannot send messages to A1 in the
interactive case the server A2 can send
messages back to A1 and in this work we
research the non-interactive case
so what can we do privately in these
models
we can use the summation with low error
in both our Central and multi-server
models
in the central model given a zero one
data set we can add LaPlace noise to the
sound
and in the multi-server model each user
can split the data by secret sharing
then sends them to different servers
and the servers now can add noise to the
sound
for the parity learning the operative
function has two parameters one is a set
of index another is a plus minus one
number B
for import X the priority function
computes B times the product of x j
uh where J is the index in the set air
and we know that we can learn the parity
function with polynomial number of
samples in the central model
and in the
multi-server model we can learn the
priority function with the same samples
against a computational bounded
adversary
so the question is that if the adversary
is computational unbounded
is it possible to learn comparative
function with the same samples in both
model
our result shows that if we want to keep
private well at most half of servers are
compromised we cannot learn the priority
function with polynomial samples against
an unbounded diversary in the
non-interactive multi-server model
uh for their techniques
the information theoretic lower bounds
for priority learning has been shown in
other works such as local model time
privacy model and Shuffle model
and in this work we show that the
non-interactive multi-server protocols
can be simulated by the internally
private protocols with low error
we at first show that the two server
protocol can be simulated by the
internally private protocol and then we
show that the multi-server protocol can
be simulated by Q server protocol
we use online algorithm as a tool in our
proof the online algorithm starts from
an inertia State and in each step it
receives one data and updates the state
at the end it computes the output by the
final state
the internally private online algorithm
is defined as for any neighboring input
x and x Prime and integer T the state t
satisfies the differential privacy
uh let's compare the Q server protocol
and the online protocol
for the initial state
we let all messages from the users to A1
and the messages from A1 to AQ to be the
initial state
and for the input data
we let the messages from the users to A2
cubies input data here uh
the message is why won't you
in the Q server protocol is the import
data X1 in the online protocol
and here the messages Y and Q in Q
server protocol is the input data xn in
online protocol
and we let A2 to start in internal state
the challenge in the our simulation is
that
storing few messages from one sample is
not private that is because
a
only one server is compromised
so uh
one one user sends two messages to the
two server separately and the adversary
cannot view both of these two messages
so we can only store one message from
one user in the internal state
if
and give a q server protocol M1 we at
first use a protocol mq to simulate M1
but M2 requires excess of the underlying
distribution but we don't know that so
it's only a thought experiment
then we use an online protocol M3 to
simulate M2 it removes the requirement
by way of rejection sampling
let's see the construction of M2 and the
M3
for the initial state
it it contains two parts
one is all messages from users qa1
another is the messages from a12a2
and let's see how to generate messages
for Server 2 in mq
for example
uh
uh it's at first consider the
distribution D conditioned on observing
y11
and then use this condition distribution
to
resembled X1 uh it is used
the base and resampling technique
and then use X1 and the
y11 to generate y12
after receiving y12 it deletes y11 in
the internal state
so
the protocol doesn't contains the two
messages from one user at the same time
it's only a short experiment because we
do not know the distribution d
so uh in M3 we figure out this problem
I'm sorry at first received some samples
from the distribution d
and it used
private rejection sampler to resample X
and use x and the y11 to generate y1q
after receiving y12 it also needs to
delete y11 from the internal state
uh in ms3 it used the rejection sampling
technique here
so uh it doesn't it doesn't need to know
the underlying distribution D it only
needs some samples from the distribution
d
and now we can extend the two server
protocol to the multi-server protocol
we assume the servers have topological
sorting that means the servers with
smaller index number can send message to
the
uh servers with larger index number but
the servers with larger index number
cannot send messages to the servers with
smaller index number
so we divide all servers into two groups
uh the first group has the
servers with smaller index numbers and
the second group
contains the servers with larger index
number
so uh
we can let a server A1 Prime to simulate
all the servers in the first group and
the A2 Prime to simulate all the servers
in the second group
and the messages from A1 Prime to A2
Prime is all the messages from the
servers in the first group to the
service in the second group
so we can use the Q server protocol to
simulate a multi-server protocol
and now we can use the lower bounds for
the internally private protocol to get
the lower bounds for the multi-server
protocol
and we know sound exists uh lower bounds
on the sample complexity for the
internally private protocol
such as the priority learning the
feature selection the simple hypothesis
test and the uniformity test
and now we can know the lower bounds on
the sample complexity for these tasks in
the multi-server protocol
the limitation of our work is that the
simulation only works for
non-interactive protocols
that is because in Japan privacy
protocol the analyst receives the data
one by one in a single pass
so for the future work
uh we can consider the lower bounds for
larger than one runs protocol because
our down interactive protocol is the one
wrong protocol but we don't know uh if
we can have larger than one round uh
what's the sample complexity of it
and we can also consider the minimum
assumptions for the sample efficient
computational DP because uh we know that
if we allowed the interactive between
the servers
the computational DP protocols can learn
the parity function with polynomial
number of samples but we don't know the
minimum assumption for the sample
efficient computational DP protocols
that's all thank you